there is a new strain of the coronavirus
in britain that could be much
more infectious in response more than 30
countries have
banned or restricted travel from the uk
some u.s officials say our existing
limits on travel from britain
need to be strengthened mts tie up is
near heathrow airport just outside
london
which is now under strict new guidelines
mts good morning
good morning yeah well for those
americans who are still hoping to fly
home for the holidays they can still get
on
one of the 18 or so flights that are
flying to the u.s from heathrow
even after that bombshell announcement
from prime minister boris johnson
about this new highly contagious strain
of the virus
given the early evidence we have on this
new variant of the
virus the potential risk it poses
it is with a very heavy heart i must
tell you we cannot
continue with christmas as planned
and with that the epicenter which
includes huge chunks of england
southeast
and london are in strict lockdown as the
new variant of covid19
surges across the region the new strain
was first detected
in september by november it made up a
quarter of
all new cases now nearly two-thirds of
infections across the uk
were being blamed on the new variant
health officials are warning it could be
up to 70 percent
more transmissible than earlier strains
raising alarm bells across the world
and in the u.s which saw its first wave
of covid19
brought over mainly from europe british
nationals aren't allowed to travel to
the u.s
but american citizens and residents
still are
right now this variant in the uk
is getting on a plane and flying
to jfk how many times in life
do you have to make the same mistake
before you learn panic nations are
slamming their borders shut to the uk
even though there's no evidence the
variant is more deadly
or reacts differently to vaccines says
infectious diseases expert
dr shira doran this is not the time to
panic
in all likelihood this is just another
mutation that leads to another strain
and that is what we have seen throughout
the pandemic
now this is a crisis like no other in a
year
like no other and it's now all up to
prime minister boris johnson's
government
to try to figure a way out of all of
this chaos
jerica all right mts tied force in
london thank you